i have a bunch of questions i want to
jump in um you have obviously worked
with or trained with jackie chan i
believe um and i'm curious do you have a
favorite jackie chan movie and a
favorite stunt
oh wow oh god you know what i never
thought about it
i really he's so incredible every single
time he's on screen he brings something
so exciting and fresh
no matter what he's doing and and and
that's why he's so successful i mean
he's just always finds a way
to reinvent himself within a genre and
it's never boring and i think that's the
thing i love about him most
yeah no i i don't think that no matter
how much praise you uh give to jackie
chan um it's never enough
i think so agreed
yeah 100 so jumping into why i get to
talk to you today uh what was it about
this script and story that said i want
to do
this it was script first it really was
and then it was talking to martin really
about what his take was going to be on
this film and
i was actually very really surprised
when i got on the phone with him the
first time because
he was so
character driven he was so
all about these relationships and i
think what i loved most about and really
essentially why i took the movie
you know at the end of the day was be it
was it was really what martin said he
didn't want even more than what he did
want there were so many things he said
we're not doing x y z abc did the efg
and and all of those things that he
didn't like about what's made in this
genre are things i didn't like and i
already knew that we were on the right
track to make something that was
different and meant more than just a
shoot em up sort of thing that you're
seeing all the time that's actually
not hard to do
oh no completely one of the things i
really enjoyed about this movie is the
way the script keeps you guessing it's
like a cat and mouse game when you don't
really know exactly where it's all going
to go exactly yeah yeah it was you know
richard he's so wonderful like that he
not only does he write great dialogue
but he also you know his misdirects are
really um
i don't know if this is gonna make sense
but they're really story driven in that
they feel organic actually to what the
characters would do once you find out
but it's not like twists for twist's
sake or oh i'm just gonna do something
for a shock factor it's like no this is
all motivated by exactly who these
people are when your friends and family
found out you're making a movie with sam
jackson and michael keaton did you all
of a sudden find a lot of people needed
to visit you on the set of this film
unfortunately i was in romania so it was
a little far for for most people but um
you know funnily enough i um i don't
even think i tell them i told them i got
the movie
i think i told them i was just going to
europe to work and they were like okay
and then
i think my sister sort of like
a couple months after we wrapped the
first part we had to go back to make the
film in august and finish it um because
of covet but
she goes um oh what were you doing and i
said i was doing a movie and she goes
who are you working with and i told her
and she goes oh my god i love that and
she was just so legit i died
so it was really funny yeah but i don't
think i actually initially told them i
think i told them later way later
that's so funny if i was your sister i'd
be like f you you're done pretty much i
mean they would see me like on letterman
or lena and they'd be like why didn't
you tell us you were on and i was like i
forgot and i did i genuinely always
forgot because i don't know i i guess i
forget that it really matters to them to
see these things
um
i read in the press notes that you said
that this film had a stunt that was
legit scary or hard can you can you talk
about which stunt that was and why was
it so challenging well and funnily
enough it's not going to be for why you
think it would be challenging so the
jump
when we rehearse the jump right you know
we obviously have a descender we're
working with you know weights and
obviously we throw sandbags off the
building for a while and then we throw
we throw it into boxes and then we throw
a stunt double off a building and you
know there's many many checks and
balances that have to happen before i
get in a wire
but so you know it's safety
as best as you can safety anything that
is like that and then but when i when i
had to rehearse
i need to see the ground right i need to
see where i'm going on the day
the stunt was i was jumping backwards
which is terrifying but at the same time
i can't rehearse jumping backwards i
need to see where i am know where the
ground is know what's going on and be
totally like body aware what's happening
so
um
i don't know if you've ever stood on the
edge of a building and just stepped off
nope me either
um and so
it was to do that going at least if
you're backwards you're not seeing the
ground
so you're sort of falling and it's it's
a terrible feeling but you you can't see
where you're going and and if if if
people are listening and they don't know
how descender works
it works with my weight and as i get
closer to the ground it's it slows down
hopefully right and so that i can
actually land
um so you're going at full speed and
then the closer you get to the ground
you start to slow down but not until you
get pretty close to the ground
so really you're just watching yourself
falling and falling and volume falling
because you're and that was just
rehearsals and
my double who was a great girl i'd never
worked with before
i i got wired in we're at the top and
she looks at me and i said how was it
she goes
it's the scariest thing i've ever done
she said i was really really scared and
i don't ever want to do it again
i was like
that was a lot of truth
like right before so it was actually the
rehearsal part but i will say that no
matter how many times we did it and we
did it many times it never got easier
i and this is
yeah i can't imagine doing something
like that yeah on that and that note i
got to stop i'm just gonna say congrats
on the movie it was really entertaining
i hope it's a huge hit for you guys
that's so nice of you to say thank you
we hope the same